Harry and Megan I've devoted about 10
minutes to them
and all of all 10 negative I thought you
watched a whole documentary and you
followed it all unimpressed with that
couple yeah to bad mouth your family
forget whether they're the Royals just
to go to the world to bad mouth your
family
I mean who doesn't have issues with
family
but to to use them
uh as as some sort of prop
to to make an impression and make and
sell a vast number of books
the these are they strike me as just
empty children
I feel bad for the royal family I mean
you know to be honest his brother has
class I love class I love I love dignity
he it's like one brother has dignity and
one brother has no dignity
anyway I got that out of my system and
by the way just out of curiosity how
much of that is on him of uh them
embarrass in the family how much of them
is on the wife you know you know the
whole thing that's unknowable but you
know
uh if it's to the extent that it's on
the wife doesn't speak much for his
strength as a man
I agree one of the definitions of
masculinity is to be not intimidated by
women
that's that's a I I I I hold that to be
a defining element that doesn't mean God
forbid you mistreat women that one has
nothing to do with the other and I mean
God forbid you but but to be intimidated
by women means you're not masculine how
did you learn that
that's a great question
how did I learn that
like that's well a book somewhere no no
I learned by your experience back back
here I feel funny but back to me and and
my brain
uh I I'm an observer of The Human
Condition one of the aims I had I had so
many AIMS in all as a kid one of them
was to understand life
if if you had to give one word to a say
what I do I explain
I try to explain life to people I try to
explain why America is in the terrible
position that it is today the freest
country in the world half of whose
citizens don't value Free Speech the
most important freedom of all I I always
ask why
and people use terms like masculine and
I value masculinity and femininity and I
believe there are only two Sexes no no I
take that back I know there are only two
Sexes I fell into a trap saying I
believe there are only two Sexes so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign
[Music]